j'ai pas de preuves de ce que j'avance
mais je pense que la personne à qui vous
pensez
l'important c'est bien ça c'est
improbable
[Musique]
et
salut bienvenue dans la troisième vidéo
du format analyse de la chaîne
aujourd'hui je vais vous expliquer
comment vous aussi vous auriez pu
trouver à quel prénom de penser une
personne dans une vidéo que j'ai fait il
ya pas longtemps le 30 décembre dernier
je suis passé dans vivement dimanche
l'émission avec michel drucker et
y'avait tom hleb et j'ai essayé de
trouver à quel prénom de quelqu'un qu'il
connaissait il pouvait penser vous aussi
vous auriez pu le trouver et c'est
exactement ce qu'on va voir aujourd'hui
mais juste avant il ya ça et maintenant
le point tournée de spectacles de fabien
olicard vous pouvez passer cette
séquence avec ce time conne mais après
faut pas le demander quand est-ce que je
passe chez vous parce que j'ai déjà fait
30 villes depuis le mois de septembre
le 22 février je serai à ribeauville le
26 à saint-etienne mais c'est complet le
10 mars à besançon le 16 mars à bias le
22 mars à arles le 23 mars à palavas le
29 mars d'attentats ski mais ça aussi
vous est complet le 30 mars à
joué-lès-tours et également une
vingtaine autres villes en france
allez sur le site pour les tchèques et
est également en suisse le 19 juin et en
belgique le 9 mai bâtonnets réservés
alors quelle technique j'ai pu employer
pour donner l'illusion de lire dans ses
pensées quels sont les détails qui ont
trahi tome hleb
c'est parti
[Musique]
on aurait aussi pu analyser mon stress
et mon non verbale parce que je suis
tout car angoissé de faire ça et je vous
dirai qu'un jour je vous ferai une vidéo
là dessus on analysera mon propre non
verbale résolutions pour l'année
prochaine c'est d'arrêter d'essayer de
lire dans la tête des gens j'aimerais
vous faire participer thomas oui
j'aimerais que vous imaginiez quelque
chose qui représente votre année 2010 9
si possible alors là je veux faire
quelque chose avec thomas solivérès mais
je vous en reparlerai à la fin de cette
vidéo là c'est une autre partie là on va
prendre ce que je vais faire avec tom
l'aide pas de résolution mais ça peut
être quelque chose qui symbolise votre
année 2010 9
ça peut être n'importe quoi sous forme
de dessin est alors pendant ce temps ben
je veux m'adresser à vous tom alors je
vais pas vous demander une bonne
résolution pour 2019 c'est pas ça l'idée
avec vous c'est de deviner qui vous avez
envie de voir absolument en 2019 une
personne peut être vous avez pas vus
depuis longtemps j'en sais rien pour le
moment
mais mon job c'est de trouver ça sur
vous j'ai pas le choix donc là c'est ce
qu'on appelle déjà un début de
suggestions imaginez on est sur un
plateau télé il ya une forme de stress
pour tout le monde pour tom aussi qui
vient faire sa propre promo pour son
spectacle et pour son concert on voit il
est des bras croisés il sait pas du tout
ce que je vais lui demander
il sait pas à quelle sauce il va être
mangé comme on dit donc il en attente de
savoir un peu ce qu'il ya mais quoi
qu'il arrive les décisions doivent être
rapides et une en stress d'où le fait
que je vienne déjà de donner des
éléments pour l'aider dans son choix
dans la suite je vous remets exactement
la phrase l'idée avec vous c'est de
deviner qui vous avez envie de voir
absolument en 2019 qui vous avez envie
de voir absolument en 2019 une personne
peut être vous avez pas vus depuis
longtemps j'en sais rien pour quelqu'un
que vous avez peut-être pas vu depuis
longtemps j'en sais rien pour le moment
quand il va devoir prendre la décision
de trouver très rapidement parce que
encore une fois c'est une émission télé
ça va très vite à qui il peut penser
mine de rien intérieurement il va rester
une trace de cette phrase et son cerveau
dans son processus de décision va avoir
tendance
j'espère à ce moment là à aller de ce
côté là c'est à dire quelqu'un qui l'a
pas vu depuis longtemps le moment mais
mon job c'est de trouver ça sur vous
j'ai pas le choix ok donc je vous
demander de penser à cette personne ok
vous me regarder dans les yeux
c'est une personne donc peu là vous avez
vu quand j'ai dit je vous demandais de
penser à cette personne je laisse un
blanc pour voir à quel moment donné il
prend sa décision
on pourra peut préjuger du temps qui va
m et quand on le voit il fait oui comme
ça c'est à dire qu'il a tout de suite
quelqu'un en tête ça veut dire pour moi
qu'il est allé très très rapidement à sa
décision à lui ça veut dire qu'a priori
il pense à quelqu'un qui l'a pas vu
depuis longtemps c'est comme une
confirmation de ce que juillet gentiment
suggéré
il aurait pu faire ce qu'ils voulaient
d'autres et je me serais adapté mais là
a priori on est sur le terrain le plus
favorable pour moi c'est une personne
donc peut-être que vous n'avez pas vu
depuis longtemps ou en tout cas vous
avez envie de voir la prochaine jusque
là tout est correct
ok vous avez pensé à la première lettre
de cette personne là j'ai juste fait une
répétition de phrases c'est peut-être
une personne que vous n'avez pas vu
depuis longtemps et en tout cas
quelqu'un vous avez envie de voir
l'année prochaine ça me permet de voir
sur son visage un espèce d'accord vous
sert on voit quand quelqu'un est
d'accord avec vous et qui vous donne une
validation non verbale ici on la voit on
a même le pléonasme physique où il le ch
la tête en disant oui ça veut dire que
ok je suis certain que c'est quelqu'un
qui n'a pas bu depuis longtemps et a
priori quelqu'un qui est encore vivant
parce qu'il y avait aussi la possibilité
de prendre quelqu'un inquiète est décédé
mais là en l'occurrence on n'y est pas
du tout et vous vous regardez dans les
yeux vous ne cherchez pas me donner
d'indiça peut être a b c d e f g h i j k
l mn au pq resté vide w x y z je pense
que j'ai passé la lettre ne rigole pas
ok on va recommencer certitude non par
contre j'ai eu un match je sais pas trop
si c'est g h i j k 7 j je sais pas si la
définition est assez bonne pour que vous
puissiez voir au ralenti mais donc j'ai
fait le très classique penser à la
première lettre
hélas si vous vous aviez regardé vous
auriez pu trouver avec ça parce que le
premier coup quand je fais tout la
lecture on voit au niveau de sa gorge
qui est une espèce de match au niveau de
jk elle est c est quand je leur fais
vous auriez pu encore mieux voir puisque
au niveau du sourcil il se libère il se
relâche
une fois que sa lettre est passé c'est à
dire qu'elle vient tout juste de passer
je vous remets la séquence très
rapidement par contre j'ai eu un match
je sais pas trop si c'est g h i j k 7 j
ok c'est s'est détendu sur j c'est
vraiment c'était un peu comme ça et
c'est passé au comme ça il s'est libéré
s'est libéré au niveau du cas quand je
dis qu'à donc ça veut dire que c'est la
lettre d'avant et c'est logique ça début
de bluff et ça m'aide à la voix rauque
et j vous savez que vous
ait pu penser à qui vous vouliez ça peut
être une femme ou un homme vous avez vu
le oui sur rome ça veut dire c'est oui
c'est agaçant voilà c'est ça qu'il est
très énervé tom vont me regarder comme
ça c'est un prénom long ou court ça veut
dire non c'est plutôt courageux le but
c'est très gentil hockey et pas la peine
de revenir trois heures je pense aussi
que vous aviez vu pourquoi c'était court
et j'ai hâte de lire vos commentaires
dites moi comment on pouvait voir à ce
moment là sur son visage que c'était un
prénom cours et moi je vais vous dire
par contre pourquoi je cherche ça parce
qu'à partir de ce moment précis j'hésite
entre trois prénoms maximum mais pas
n'importe comment
parce que j'ai fait ce qu'on appelle du
stock reading c'est à dire j'ai lu la
biographie de tom hleb avant de venir je
savais qu'il était dans l'émission
donc j'ai lu rapidement sa bio et je
sais plusieurs choses sur lui je sais
qu'il a passé cinq ans aux états unis et
qu'il en est revenu il ya vraiment pas
mal d'années donc ça fait très longtemps
qu'il n'y ait pas retourné je sais que
c'est là-bas qu'il a appris à faire de
la musique du théâtre la comédie je sais
que c'est là-bas qu'il a trouvé les
personnes qui ont été ses mentors qu'il
leur révéler artistiquement et du coup
le gip correspondent à l'une des
personnes qu'il a rencontrées et qu'on
peut lire dans sa bio donc c'est à ce
moment précis que j'ai besoin de savoir
si c'est un prénom longs ou courts pour
voir si je peux trier dans les infos que
j'ai lu juste avant de rentrer sur scène
dès que j'ai su qu'il était invité
j'ai pas de preuves de ce que j'avance
mais je pense que la personne à qui vous
pensez
j'ai pensé à de jonathan mais je pense
que ça aide jeune j'ai un gros doute
quand même sur le fait de peut-être
m'être trompé sur la longueur du prénom
et je me dis jonathan c'est quand même
possible et l'âge utilise une technique
très fourbe de mentalist pour voir si je
suis pas en train de me planter jeudi au
début j'avais pensé que c'était jonathan
mais je pense que c'est john et en
disant ça simplement j'ai dit jonathan
et j'ai regarder du coin de l'oeil en
vision périphérique quelle était la
réaction sur son visage est ce qu'il y
avait là surprise la joie de la
déception de l'étonnement il n'y avait
rien ce qui veut dire que ce n'est pas
ça et du coup je continue ma phrase si
ça avait été cela j'aurais sûrement
transformer un truc du style
au début je me suis dit que ça pouvait
être jonathan et puis plus je vous ai
parlé plus je le vois maintenant eh oui
c'est jonathan et on aimerait terminer
dessus c'est une espèce de porte de
sortie que je me suis offerte à ce
moment là
au cas où je suis en train de planter et
sa murray un peu fait chier quand même
c'est ça c'est bien ça c'est improbable
ça c'est qu'ils jones en vous cki jonway
c'est celui qui m'a influencé à jouer de
la guitare et vous pensiez à john là
exactement mais est exactement la même
merci beaucoup
et donc c'était john la personne qui l'a
influencé à jouer de la guitare ça en
l'occurrence ne le savait pas mais du
coup le fait de savoir ça sur sa vie je
savais que c'était potentiellement un
prénom américain est quelqu'un qui
l'avait rencontré aux états unis et
c'est comme ça que j'ai pu le déduire et
jeu quand je lui demande qui sait par
rapport à lui là c'est vraiment de la
curiosité de ma part parce que je me dis
alors est ce que toutes mes théories
était bonne et est ce que j'ai réussi à
l'emmener sur ce territoire là et c'est
ce qui s'est passé du coup à la fin on
se dit ah ouais ok c'est normal qu'ils
pensent à lui mais il aurait pu penser a
tellement d'autres personnes qui ont
marqué sa vie
peut-être même des personnes qui l'a
jamais rencontré ou des personnes de sa
famille ou des amis
là c'était lié au domaine artistique il
va nous en parler un petit peu après
donc ici on voit également sur le visage
du petit au lit car tous les symboles du
soulagement pour moi c'est fait parce
que là j'ai pas encore conscience qu'il
va falloir que je continue avec thomas
se libérer c'est ça est encore plus
difficile
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas quoi vous dire à ce que
vous avez terminé thomas l'a forcément
ça va continuer avec thomas solivérès
alors je vais pas vous mettre la vidéo
en entier ici parce qu'on va pas faire
l'analyse de ça maintenant
néanmoins si vous avez envie de voir ce
passage également en entier sans que ce
soit coupé avec moi qui vous parle je
vais vous mettre un bien non répertoriés
dans la description ce qui vous
permettra d'aller voir ça c'est pas mal
ça loïc du coup tu pourra leur faire un
montage
ouais ça me fait penser pourquoi souvent
on trafique l'image est pourquoi on hamm
est directement dans l'écran de
l'ordinateur avec loïc je vous explique
pourquoi parce que en réalité france
télévisions a les droits de cette vidéo
et je ne suis pas censé pouvoir la
diffuser
et si l'algorithme le détecte et bella
vidéo sera strike et vous ne pourrez pas
la regarder
c'est pour ça que c'est pas forcément
très agréable toujours de vous de votre
côté regarder la vidéo comme ça il ya un
petit lien non répertoriés qui emmène
sur sur ma chaîne secondaire c'est moins
grave si elle se fait strike et la
chaîne secondaire ce qui était
intéressant aussi dans cette vidéo c'est
que si vous regardez depuis le départ
concentrez vous maintenant sur les
émotions que pouvaient ressentir tome
hleb au début il n'y a pas forcément
envie de faire
ça au début il sait pas exactement ce
qu'on va faire et au fur et à mesure il
est emmené dans le jeu par sa propre
émotion parce que le fait de penser à
quelqu'un qu'il a envie de voir l'année
prochaine ça le met dans une émotion
positive tu prendras quelqu'un qui a
envie de voir quelqu'un qui te manque
donc tu es forcément heureux de penser à
cette personne et ça te met dans un bon
mood et ça ça m'aide aussi mois à
travailler sur ce numéro de mentalisme
mais vous aussi avec ces quelques
détails que je viens de vous donner vous
auriez pu essayer de faire en même temps
que moi avec pas forcément toujours la
même technique mais par rapport à langue
que vous avez c'était les meilleurs
techniques à utiliser
vous avez donc la suite avec thomas
solide et reste dans la description pour
la prochaine analyses proposées mois
dans les commentaires qu'est ce que vous
voudriez que j'analyse j'ai pas mal de
pistes d'idées il faut juste que ce soit
quelque chose qui soit intéressant et d
analyse factuelle de personnes pas des
trucs on prend position
comme j'avais fait avec mâcon j'avais
essayé d'être le plus neutre et factuel
possible
n'oubliez pas de me rajouter sur
instagram ça m'arrive de faire des
analyses très rapide en story sur des
trucs qui mériterait pas une vidéo
n'oubliez pas de cliquer cette vidéo si
ce concept là vous plaît vous pouvez
vous abonner
pourquoi eh bien regardez analyse non
verbale parce qu apparemment ça compte
pour moi oui c'est très important que
vous vous abonniez si vous regardez les
vidéos pour être prévenu des nouvelles
ici vous avez la dernière vidéo en date
ici c'est youtube qui vous propose une
vidéo qui est fait pour vous parce que
youtube vous a analysé
à très bientôt ciao